welcome back
so i've been talking about the laplace
transform and how
this generalizes the notion of a fourier
transform to a much larger class of
systems
and now i'm going to show you how you
can use the laplace transform
to turn a system of ordinary
differential equations
into a much simpler algebraic system of
equations
this is really cool that you can
essentially
take a kind of college differential
equation problem and turn it into a high
school algebra problem
just using the laplace transform all
right so the example i'm going to work
on
we're going to look at the spring mass
damper system because this is a really
fun easy system to work with
and it's very intuitive we kind of know
what
the physics of this system
should behave as okay so we have a mass
m
we have a spring with spring constant k
and a damper
with some damping coefficient c and what
we
care about is the position x of this
mass
away from equilibrium so at rest will be
x equals zero
and if we pull this mass over out of
equilibrium and let it go
we're going to see it oscillate and
eventually damp
or die out and go back to zero because
of the stamping coefficient
okay and the differential equation for
this system is quite simple to write
down
we can write this down as x double dot
plus c over m
x dot plus k over
m x equals zero
okay and so what we're going to do is
we're going to take the laplace
transform of this differential equation
we're going to turn it from an ordinary
differential equation a second order
ordinary differential equation
into an algebraic equation in terms of
the laplace variable
so remember uh dot means time derivative
so this is a velocity the velocity of x
and the acceleration of x and this
formula is just
a statement of newton's second law of
motion force equals mass times
acceleration
so this is acceleration if i move these
masses over this would be mass times
acceleration
and these would be the forces from the
damper and from the spring so this is
just newton's second law
written as a differential equation and
what i'm going to do
is i'm going to for simplicity i'm going
to assume
that c and k and m are
positive integers to make my life a lot
easier so i'm going to assume
that my actual differential equation is
x double dot
plus five x dot plus
four x equals zero so i'm going to
assume that my mass is one
c is five and k is four and that's going
to make everything a lot easier
i'm also going to assume that i have
initial conditions because i can't solve
the system without initial conditions
so i'm also going to assume that i know
x
at time 0 and x dot at time 0.
and i'm going to assume that those are 2
and minus 5. and so what that means
is that x 0 being 2 means i pull this 2
units over in the positive direction and
x dot equals minus five means that i
start it with an initial velocity so i
kind of kick it
in that direction with a velocity of
minus five so i pull it over here
and then i kick it with a velocity of
minus five and that's my initial
condition that starts this thing ringing
and oscillating
and so those of you who know about
ordinary differential equations i'm
assuming most of you
know that the eigenvalues of this system
are going to determine kind of how the
system responds to this initial
condition
and i'm probably going to get things
like exponential functions
or sines and cosines depending on k and
c
now in this case k is pretty large uh so
i'm assuming i might guess
i might not have any uh oscillations
this thing might just uh
be over damped and go right back to the
to the starting point
okay good so let's see um
now what we're going to do is we are
going to laplace transform
this basic uh equation of motion
okay so that's what i'm going to do do
here so i'm going to laplace transform
this equation and i'm going to start
with the laplace transform of x double
dot
so the laplace transform of x double dot
and i wrote down all of my formulas here
that we derived last time
so um this is this in blue is just the
laplace transform
in red is the laplace transform of a
first derivative
you get s times the laplace transform of
f minus the initial condition
and in green we have the laplace
transform of the second derivative x
double dot
or f double dot is s squared times the
laplace transform
minus s times my initial condition minus
my initial velocity
so here just plug in x's for f's and
that's what we're going to do here
so the laplace transform of x double dot
is
s squared x bar i'm going to use bar for
my laplace variable
minus s times
x naught minus x
dot not okay that's exactly what i wrote
here
but with x's instead of f's for my time
derivative
so that is the laplace transform of the
first term
now i need the laplace transform of the
second term and the third term so i'm
going to write that out
plus and i'm going to have 5
times the laplace transform of x dot is
going to be s
x bar minus
x naught i hope that's right s
x bar minus x not good that's this term
plus 4 times
x bar and that whole thing equals
0. so what i've done is i've taken the
laplace transform
this is 5 times the laplace transform of
x dot
and this is four times the laplace
transform of x
okay so i've just literally
taken this equation and laplace
transformed every single term
now this is super cool notice that in
this expression here i have no more
derivatives
all that i have are x bars which is the
laplace transform of
you know x bar is just the laplace
transform of x of t
my solution so i want to take my
solution laplace transform it and then i
can go back and forth
so i have x bars i have initial
conditions
and i have polynomial polynomials in x
in s so i've taken my differential
equation and it's turned into
an algebraic equation or a polynomial in
s
so all of my derivatives turned into
polynomials in s
and if i had an x triple dot or an x
quadruple dot i would have an
s cubed or an s to the fourth and so
this allows you to take very very
complex differential equations and turn
them into relatively simple
polynomials in s okay so now let's go
through and actually solve
this system of equations using this
simplified laplace transform
notation and i'm just going to say this
is like the laplace transform
implies this equation is true good
okay so what do i want to do i'm going
to collect all of my x bar terms
so i'm going to collect yeah collect
x bar and so i have an s
squared plus five
s plus four
all times x bar of s okay so the only
terms that have an x bar of s that have
my actual solution
are this s squared five s and four so
now
this is all of my terms that have my x
bar
and i'm going to have all of the other
terms that have these initial conditions
i'm going to move those over to the
right hand side
so now i'm going to have how do i want
to collect these i'm going to collect
these like
now i have s times x naught and x naught
is just 2 so i have 2s
plus a minus 5 minus 5.
and i'm going to add 5 x naught over so
plus sorry so this is minus 10 so it
becomes plus 10 over here
good and i hope i did this right there's
always a chance
i didn't but this whole thing equals
2s plus 5. good
so now this is really cool what have i
done i laplace transformed my
differential equation
and i have a bunch of terms that are in
terms of x bar and a bunch of terms that
are in terms of my initial conditions
i collect all of my x bars on one side
and all of my initial condition terms on
the other so let me just make a little
under bar these are all of my initial
conditions
and you'll notice that this polynomial
here this polynomial is the
characteristic polynomial of this
differential equation
so my second derivative became an s
squared plus five first derivative
became plus five
s plus four x became plus 4 x bar
and so my my differential equation
remember if you plugged in e to the
lambda t
you would get this polynomial in lambda
and that would tell you what the
eigenvalues or the solutions are
so this is the characteristic polynomial
of this this polynomial this poly
in s is the characteristic
uh characteristic poly of
our ode and that's really really
useful okay so now what we are going to
do is we are going to divide
this polynomial on both sides to solve
for x bar
because we eventually want like what i
want at the end of this differential
equation is x of t
equals something i want to know what the
position is in time that's the solution
of my differential equation
so i'm going to solve for x bar and then
i'm going to inverse laplace transform
good so i'm going to solve for x bar
inverse laplace transform so x bar of s
equals this polynomial here 2
s plus 5 over
my characteristic polynomial s squared
plus
five s plus four
okay now
now you might be wondering how do i
inverse laplace transform
this function well we do have a nice
little
formula here i'm just going to extend
this that the
the laplace transform of e to the a
t equals 1 over
s minus a okay so
if we have 1 over s minus a we know that
the inverse laplace transform
is e to the a t and so what i'm going to
do is i'm going to use
partial fractions to split this
function into the sum of two functions
that look like this where there's only a
monomial in the denominator
and so i'm going to write this as 2
s plus 5 over
and i'm going to split this polynomial i
chose those numbers because it's easy
to do this is s plus
4 times s plus
1. if you multiply those out you get
this polynomial
now for those of you who know
differential equations you'll recognize
that the eigenvalues of this the
solutions of this characteristic
polynomial
are minus 4 and minus 1. so that's
that's good
and now i can write this as
what is this i mean i chose really easy
numbers so this ends up being 1 over s
plus 4 plus 1 over s plus
1. and you can verify that if you cross
multiply
these you get 2s plus 5
over this expression here so that is
true
if you didn't know if
if i didn't make an easy problem what
you would do is you would call this
a and b and you would solve for a and b
so that when you cross multiplied you
recovered two s plus
five that's how you do this in general
for partial fractions but i chose
easy initial conditions and easy k and c
so that this all works out to be
integers
okay good and now i have the sum
of two easy functions that i know how to
inverse laplace transform
and because the laplace transform is a
linear operator just like the fourier
transform is a linear operator
really important it means that the
inverse laplace transform of this sum
is the sum of each of the individual
inverse laplace transforms
so i inverse laplace transform this and
i inverse laplace transform that
and i get x of t
equals the inverse laplace transform of
one over s plus four which is e to the
minus
four t remember a here
is minus four so minus four t
plus e to the minus one
t and that is
the solution of the differential
equation
using that's the worst star i've ever
drawn
using the laplace transform all right
let's take a step back
and let's summarize what we did so i've
told you that the laplace transform
takes three years off of an advanced
math problem
and in this case we took our ordinary
differential equation
and when we laplace transform it we get
an algebraic equation
in terms of polynomials of s so every
derivative of
x becomes a higher order polynomial of
s and so you get this expression and
this is super nice remember when you
solve differential equations
you would first solve for the general
solution e to the
lambda t plus e to the lambda 2 t and
then you would solve for the
coefficients
that satisfy the initial conditions this
handles it all at once because when you
laplace transform this equation
the initial conditions are in in that
laplace transform
so when i collect my x bar terms the
laplace transform of my solution
i get my characteristic polynomial and
on the right hand side i get terms that
come from my initial conditions
and so when i solve this system using
partial fractions and inverse laplace
transform i get the coefficients
that satisfy these initial conditions
for free
automatically very very cool okay
excellent
um fun fact about laplace i always think
this is cool laplace is just such a
fascinating character you should
definitely read about him
uh brilliant mathematician his name's on
the eiffel tower
first time i saw it it blew me away that
the french revere their mathematicians
so um laplace
was the first person that i'm aware of
that unified
the idea of least squares regression
that legendre
came up with and the idea of gaussian
probability probability ola gauss
and so kind of bringing those together
to think of least squares as a
probabilistic regression
uh is due to laplace he also proved
the first central limit theorem in
statistics which is
the cornerstone uh of of statistics and
kind of the law
of large numbers okay so really
important character laplace
and in addition to having transformative
impact and probability
he also showed us how to generalize the
fourier transform
to make ordinary differential equations
much much simpler
okay last parting thought let's see if i
can do this without ruining my board
too much is that if
this function had some external forcing
so instead of just looking at the free
response where i look at just just the
natural dynamics
if this was plus
let's say this equaled some forcing u of
t
so i was actively forcing the system
with some external forcing u of t
then when i laplace transform this uh
zero would become a u bar
of s i would just laplace transform my
forcing then i would have my initial
conditions
um plus
u bar so i'd have a plus you know my
control
or forcing so this is how this also is
useful for control
is that you might externally force the
system to make it behave a certain way
with some u of t that you decide on
in that case we would call this a
control and so
then basically the this you do the same
thing you divide
by your characteristic polynomial you
get your initial condition response
plus let me see if i can do this without
ruining
the board plus
u bar over s squared plus five
s plus four now this is a little harder
to inverse laplace transform this
expression here you would
you basically have to do the same
partial fraction trick
for one over s squared plus five s plus
4
and then you would take the inverse
laplace transform of that and take the
convolution integral with the inverse
laplace transform of u
so i'll talk more about this later but
what i really want to get across here
is that this system allows you to
simultaneously capture
the natural dynamics from the
differential equation from f equals m a
that's captured here in this
characteristic polynomial
the initial conditions are naturally
captured in these initial conditions
when you do this laplace transform here
and the effective control or forcing can
also be naturally incorporated in the
right hand side
and that just gives you another plus
convolution integral term
here so really powerful framework to
solve
differential equations with initial
conditions with external forcing all in
this kind of unified framework
all in terms of algebraic equations
using the laplace transform
super cool thank you